Let's go next to let's go to Brant from Lubbock,
I presume Lubbock, Texas. Is that right, Brant?
That is correct, sir. Lubbock,
Texas. What's going on there?
Not much, man. Everybody's kind of. We're
having some surges and covered cases. So,
yeah, you know, not much is going on. Ready to
get going back home next weekend to vote and
vote in person. Very good. But what can I do for
you today? Yeah, I had a question. Do you believe
that a Biden administration will do decriminalize
marijuana like they say they will? And on top of
that, do you think they would potentially go
a step further than decriminalization since
Mexico is poised to legalize recreational use?
I think it's very unlikely that during a first
Biden term, legalization happens. And if you if
you can mute your discord so we're not hearing
the constant beeps, that would be really, really
good. In fact, I may just mute you and and answer
the rest of it. Off-line just so because it's
quite distracting. I do believe Joe Biden will
Dick will try to decriminalize. If he is able to
do it is going to depend on some factors beyond
his control. But I do believe so. I mean, listen,
in general, politicians when running for president
make promises that they can't always keep and
that sometimes they don't intend to keep. I
don't think that's any different with Joe
Biden. But I do believe we are going to see,
particularly if Democrats take the Senate. A good
faith effort made to decriminalize marijuana. And
I hope we see it. And then I hope that that's just
step one. And then we go we go further from there.
If you love feeding your intellectual curiosity,
but you're always struggling to find the time,
check out one of my all time favorite apps called
Blankest. Blankest lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work. They take thousands
of popular nonfiction books, condense each one
into text or audio that you can get through in
just 15 minutes. And you get all of the important
core ideas and information from that book.
It's perfect. If you don't have enough time
to do all the reading you want to do, or if you
just want to sample a book before you buy the
entire thing. I recently read a brief history of
time, of course, by the great Stephen Hawking.
This is a book that I have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on Blankest. Blankest
has books on politics, philosophy, science. They
have 27 different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a month.
And you get the entire library, but you can try it
totally free and get 25 percent off a subscription
when you go to blink dot com slash Pacman.
I've put the link right underneath this video.